Can you hazard a guess what Europe is
clamping down on speech critical of
Islam when Islam is causing lots of
problems with rape,
gangs,
terrorism,
and generally being a menace?
Why?
Well,
I suppose the first,
let's say if I was going to oppose that
statement,
I would say,
well,
perhaps it's a propaganda stick.
Uh,
uh,
what would you call it,
conspiracy to blame what's happening in
Europe on Islamic immigrants?
I guess part of the problem is,
is that at least as far as I can tell,
the news has become sufficiently
unreliable because it's so polarized
that we can't really tell what's going
on.
I mean,
I think the reason that Europe is
clamping down on speech critical of
Islam is partly the same reason that the
entire Western world is clamping down on
speech that's critical of anything that
is associated with group identity,
which is pretty much any set of ideas
that unites people and it's,
it's a consequence of the collective
decision that we've made.
That egalitarianism and a conflict
avoidance constitute the two highest
virtues and they trump everything else
including free speech.
Now why that's happened is very,
very difficult thing to say.
I mean I'm,
I suspect to some degree that it's a
consequence of women becoming involved
in the political system,
which is something that we've never
experienced before and women are more
agreeable by nature than men and I'm
variable.
People are are compassionate towards
those.
They see a suffering and that seems to
include any minority,
especially when you combine that with a
kind of neo Marxist doctrine that claims
that anyone who has an advantage swiped
it.
And I think in the Islamic situation,
you get it real conflict there because
it's obviously the case that many
Islamic practices are not commensurate
with postmodern neo Marxist feminism,
let's say.
But they seem to get a free pass.
And I guess that's because the idea that
all cultures are equal trumps the
requirement for human rights for women.
And.
And maybe the other thing that's even
darker is that there's a fair bit of
revolutionary fervor in the more radical
end of the political spectrum.
And that radical fervor is devoted
towards tearing down the patriarchy.
And of course that's basically Western
civilization.
And so if,
because Islam isn't part of Western
civilization,
than it can be seen as an ally in that,
in that attempt,
that's what it looks like to me.
I also think that ignorance and and all
of that contribute.
It isn't obvious that people who are
afraid of such things as Islamophobia
really understand anything about Islam
wouldn't say I understand anything about
Islam.
Even though I've read a fair bit about
it,
it's very difficult to put yourself
inside a different belief system.
I'm somewhat apprehensive about Islam
because it looks to me like it's a
totalizing system as well as a religion
and it's a totalizing system because
everything has to come under his
purview,
including law and and everything that
goes along with that.
There's no separation between church and
state.
And so I don't see how that's
commensurate with the western mode of
existence.
And I don't think people want to have
that conversation because they want to
say,
well no,
everyone diverse as they are.
And important as that diversity is
apparently such that everyone has to be
represented equally.
The diversity isn't really of anything
about anything fundamental and we can
all get along without a problem and I'm
afraid that that's extraordinarily
naive.
And then I suppose there's also an
element of something like Western guilt,
I guess perhaps for what has been
described as our imperialist past,
um,
the,
there's been a very longterm assault
on,
on the,
what would you call it,
moral
on the morality of the West.
We're often viewed as the rapers and
pillagers of the world and that sort of
goes along with the environmentalist
ethos.
And so I think we do have a fair bit of
guilt about that,
whether it's warranted or not.
Um,
I mean history is a bloody nightmare and
it doesn't matter where you look.
And I would say at least in the West has
brought advantages along with its
disadvantages.
And I think that our attitude towards
individuality is fundamentally correct
and absolutely vital.
And I would also say that the only
countries in the world that are
essentially worth living in,
in any real sense are the ones that are
predicated on the Judeo Christian
tradition and manifested in western the
western body of laws.
So,
but there's still plenty of guilt and
there's plenty of people who,
well,
who are,
what contemptuous of being,
as we discussed it,
the last question and also angry with
the political system because they're
powerless or maybe they've been hurt by
male authority figures.
Um,
and that happens very frequently.
And so they have absolutely no trust in
higher in hierarchical structures.
And there you might add to that to a
certain amount of laziness because the
thing about hierarchical structures is
that they impose values on people.
And then in order to progress in that
value structure that you have to
discipline yourself and work hard.
And many of the radical leftists
happened to be very low in
conscientiousness.
And so they don't believe in hard work
and they don't believe that people get
to where they're going by hard work.
And,
well,
one other thing,
there's a group of people I think who
were basically personality disordered
in,
those are the ones that had never had a
positive relationship with anything that
was masculine.
And so whenever they see anything
masculine that has motive power and that
would include authority and competence,
not just power,
they assume that that's tyrannical and
it's part of the postmodern assumption
that all power higher,
all hierarchies are hierarchies of power
when the truth of the matter is,
is that hierarchies in the West are
usually hierarchies of authority and
competence and they're like,
they're oriented towards getting a
certain task done and they actually do
get the task done.
So,
but we're,
I'm dubious about our own ethical.
Um,
what would you say?
Integrity.
And I guess that's also why it's a
particular importance for people to try
to act honestly,
because if you don't act honestly and
then you start to doubt your own
integrity and then when people come
after you,
you're going to be weak.
And that's a really bad idea.
So.